en mai un vol de 25 heures sans
carburant c'est le défi que tentent de
relever en ce moment l'équipe de
l'explorateur bertrand piccard
depuis ce matin un appareil expérimental
propulsé grâce à l'énergie solaire
survolent la suisse hans charline anbar
dans le monde des avions solar impulse a
le gabarit d'une libellule un poids
plume de 1600 kg qui n'a que pour seul
carburant l'énergie solaire c'est
vraiment un moment spécial très
important toute l'équipe attend ça
depuis le début depuis presque sept ans
partis ce matin solar impulse tourner en
rond au-dessus de la suisse à une
vitesse de 35 km heure pour réaliser
l'exploit
il ne devrait toucher terre que demain
matin 25 heures de vol de jour comme de
nuit
un défi qui met à rude épreuve le
prototype on croise les doigts on avance
dans l'inconnu car rien n'est certain
temps déjà connu en 1999 pour son tour
du monde en ballon
bertrand piccard et son équipe espèrent
cette fois faire de même avec solar inc
pulse d'ici 2013 au gré des vents et des
12000 cellules photovoltaïques disposés
sur les ailes